ما في اتصالات وهنا فكروني طلعت انا وانه
بعدوا يعني موقف كثير صعب يعني لهلق ببرك
واقعد بصرخ الارض عم بتهز الارض عم بتهز
اي لهلق ولهلا اذا هلق بركي والله وحاسه
انه الارض بتهز فيا
وعم نصيح انا ثلاثه ايام مرقة من جنبي
عالم ما حد بيطلع حدا وانت تصرخي وما حد
يسمعك
من كثر ما انا بدي اسمع انا بدي اسمع هذه
التجربه ولو انها يعني دموعك
عم بصير بس ما حد عم تشوفون قدامي عم
بشوفهم المطر عم تنزل علينا
بس انا صاحي بعد نهار ما بعرف شو صار
مطر تحت المطر والبرد وصدره يمكن كلياته
عبا فيها وصيح راح صوتك
الحمد لله لا الحمد لله يعني هون شوي بس
ظهري شوي الحمد لله
طيب ثلاث ايام اللي عشتيها تحت الانقاض
انت لديك تجربه مرعبه يعني انا اعرف
واعتذر يعني
بدون ما عطشتي جعتي ايش ايش اللي شعرت فيه
البرد
صعب وين صاروا لانه هن طلعوا يعني قلت لها
بعديهم وانا انهدتها انا طلعت بعد ما طبت
وانا فكرته لانه هن راحت طبت عليا
من انقذك كيف صارت عمليه الانقاذ
ثلاثه ايام راح صوتي